بعدما تم اجلاء عدد كبير من الرعايه
الهنود من السودان عبر السلطات السعوديه
الى قاعده الملك فيصل البحري او حتى الى
قاعده الملك عبد الله الجويه وحتى كذلك
عبر ميناء جده الاسلامي اليوم يستعد 185
مواطن هندي السفر الى بلدانهم بعد ان تم
انهاء كافه اجراءات السفر الخاصه بذلك
اليوم كاميرا العربيه سوف ترافق هذه
الرحله او هؤلاء الرعايه حتى وصولهم الى
الطائره ايرباص رقم الطائره السبعه ثلاثه
موجه الى الهند وتحديدا الى مدينه كوتشين
الهنديه نتحدث انه سوف تستغرق الرحله
قرابه الخمس الساعات نتحدث عن هذه الرحله
هي الرحله هي الخامسه التي سوف تتوجه الى
الهند بعد ان اقلعت خمسه او غادرت خمسه
طائرات من مطار الملك عبد العزيز الدولي
بجده الى الهند في
السعوديه كم مكثوا في السعوديه بعد وصولهم
من السودان
ساعه فقط بعد ان اجلتهم السلطات السعوديه
من ميناء بورت السودان الى مدينه جده عبر
السفن البحريه السعوديه او حتى الارسال
يتقطع قليلا الجو عبر
48 ساعه قلت لانه الارسال يتقطع يعني
يصلنا متقطع
في القطار
نعم 48 ساعه نتحدث عن قرابه 1500 مواطن
هندي تم مغادرتهم الى بلدانهم بعد ان تم
اجلائهم من السودان وصولا الى مدينه جده
عبر قاعه الملك فيصل حتى عبر ميناء جده
الاسلامي او حتى كذلك عبر قاعده الملك عبد
الله الجويه ولا تزال العمليات الاجلاء
مستمره من السودان الى مدينه جده وفي ظرف
48 ساعه يتم انهاء كافه اجراءات السفر
الخاصه بهم ومنحهم تاشيرات استثنائيه من
قبل المديريه العامه للجوازات حتى يتسنى
هؤلاء حتى يتسنى لهؤلاء الرعايه السفر الى
بلدانهم في بعض الموقف الانساني او
المواقف الصعبه التي عاشها هنالك في
السودان اليوم الحكومه السعوديه تعمل على
تقديم جمله وحزمه كبيره من البرامج
والخدمات للتسهيل على هؤلاء الرعايه حتى
ان يصلوا الى بلدانهم بالتنسيق مع
حكوماتهم نتحدث عن اعداد كبيره تعمل على
اجلام الحكومه الحكومه السعوديه منذ بدء
الاشتباكات المسلحه هناك في السودان الجيش
السوداني وبين قوات الدعم السريع في ظرف
ثواني محدوده سوف نصل الى طائره ايرباص
رقم سبعه ثلاثه سبعه هذه الطائره الهنديه
التي تسمى بسبايس جت شركه خطوط هنديه هي
المسؤوله والتي سوف تقوم بنقل هؤلاء
الركاب الى مدينه كوتشين الهنديه وهي
الرحله الخامسه التي تغادر من مدينه جده
الى المدن الهنديه ايضا الرعايه الصينيين
كانوا يغادروا قبل 48 ساعه من الان وكان
عددهم قرابه الثلاثه وسبعه واربعين مواطن
صيني وكانت هذه هي اعداد كافه الرعايه
الصينيه الذين غادروا الذين وصلوا من
بورتسودات تحديدا الى السعوديه وكان قد
غادروا قبل 48 ساعه الان كما نتحدث نشاهد
اعداد كبيره من هؤلاء الرعايه نتحدث عن
عائلات واطفال واعداد كبيره جدا من هؤلاء
الرعايه الذين عاشوا تفاصيل اوقات الصعبه
جدا خلال الايام الماضيه عندما كانوا في
السودان اليوم الحكومه السعوديه قامت
باجلاها هؤلاء الرعايه وايصالهم الى جده
وبعد ذلك تقديم كافه الخدمات
التموينيه والاعاشيه والطبيه والصحيه
لهؤلاء الرعايه وكذلك منحهم تاشيرات
استثنائيه حتى يتسلل هؤلاء الرعايه انهاء
الاجراءات السفر الخاصه بهؤلاء حتى ان
يصلوا الى بلدانهم هذا التعامل يتم
التعامل به مع كافه الرعايه بمختلف
جنسياتهم واديانهم ايضا الان متوقع ان
وصلنا الى هذه الطائره
نعم موقع الان قد يفتح هذا الباب الان
اسمحوا لنا بس نقدر نعدي الان نعم ممكن
تفضل زميلنا مصور عصام
[موسيقى]
لمتابعه المزيد من الاخبار والبرامج
والقصص الانسانيه والوثائقيات والتقارير
الاخباريه لا تنسوا الاشتراك في قناتنا
على اليوتيوب الضغط على زر الاعجاب وتفعيل
جرس التنبيهات